do you have advice on how to be
happy yes there's a lot of loneliness
and sadness in the world uh here I can
give a very easy piece of advice that
worked a lot for
me instead of telling
yourself that you have these ridiculous
standards tell yourself I can be
better right I don't have to be a great
writer I could be a better writer I
don't have to be a great podcaster that
will never happen I could be a better
podcaster I could be a better person I
could be a better uh at the gym I could
be better with my time and when you
regard things in the and especially if
you have metrics that you can go by you
know for I I'll run this many miles a
day things you have control over if you
especially as males when you have this
chart and the data is telling you you're
improving right away it's like you have
the sense of accomplishment so I think
that is a really great way to uh uh find
and if something is not working your
life let's suppose you don't have
friends right there's the internet how
do people make friends try things out
what's the worst that's going to happen
you're going to things blow up in your
face well you're you're you learned
something at least don't be afraid of
making mistakes when I was a kid I was
so scared of having things under control
so like I would never have to get hit in
the face orally and then I realized and
you realized this as well everyone who's
important gets hit in the face look at
the president whoever the president is
it becomes a matter of being strong
enough that you could take getting hit
in the face so that is a big important
switch in your thinking yeah there's a
Bowski quote I wrote
down sometimes you climb out of bed in
the morning and you think I'm not going
to make it but you laugh inside
remembering all the times you felt that
way yeah yeah there's a part of me that
that's like that there's some days where
I feel like this is the worst day of my
life and then like shortly after I think
like chuckle at that yes just knowing
the ups and downs of the brain and the
mind and life and all that you ever been
depressed yeah of course I'm more
anxious than depressed I don't really
get depressed I like yeah but I've been
depressed like low points yeah but I
think I I distinguish depression between
low points right like if things are
going bad and you feel bad that makes
sense but I I when I think of depression
I think of someone who feels bad when
things aren't bad like it's it's by to
me it's like almost by definition
irrational well yeah and there's
different kinds of I like there there's
a exhausted kind of depression where
you're not it's not so much sad is
you're not don't want to do anything you
you're you don't want to live you don't
want to what's the yeah what's the point
what's the point RP yeah um and like an
extreme self-critical negativity which
I'm also scared of because my brain is
generally very self critical cuz you're
not taking up magnesium do you take erec
or in the mouth you take erec okay but
as for as for the Magnesium you should
take it as a pill okay well the way your
mom explained it then is is way
different